si monsieur jacob la parole est
maintenant monsieur marc fesneau pour le
groupe mouvement démocrate et apparentés
monsieur le président rainaud vous avez
la parole monsieur le président monsieur
le premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
mesdames et messieurs les députés chers
collègues avec l'élection du président
de la république et de l'instant et de
l'assemblée que nous constituons les
français ont fait le choix d'une
alternance véritable et d'un
bouleversement du paysage politique que
nous connaissions depuis des décennies
ce bouleversement n'est pas le fruit du
hasard
il est la conséquence directe d'années
d'échecs de promesses non tenues d'un
capacité à conduire des réformes
profondes que le pays attendait et
finalement ce choix nous oblige tous
monsieur le premier ministre le
gouvernement que vous conduisez
s'inscrit pleinement dans cette volonté
de recomposition de la vie politique à
laquelle vous avez pris toute votre part
en dépassant les clivages stérile
artificielle et finalement inefficace il
nous sommes donc ici avec la modestie de
ceux qui savent et qui ont vu les échecs
du passé et avec l'ambition ferme
monsieur le premier ministre de ce
qu'ils entendent pouvoir rompre avec le
mâle ferme français d'alternance inutile
de rendez vous manqués et d'espoirs
déçus
vous me permettrez à ce stade de dire un
mot de la recomposition politique à
l'oeuvre j'entendais hier au congrès
avec un peu étonnant certains de nos
collègues de l'assemblée ou du sénat
douter de l'efficacité ou la lisibilité
de cette recomposition dépasser les
clivages anciens ce ne sont pas des mots
creux ce n'est pas renoncer aux
différences et affadir les débats s'est
rassemblée ce qui sur les grands enjeux
essentiels pense depuis bien longtemps
la même chose et que la bipolarisation
artificiel avait séparé et empêcher de
travailler ensemble
et c'est au contraire et finalement
amener de la clarté et constituaient la
majorité et les oppositions sur ce que
sont vraiment les véritables lignes de
parti de fracture entre nous alors
monsieur forme sur le président faure je
ne sais pas si la politique qui va être
menée sera de droite et de gauche vous
l'après appellerez finalement bien comme
vous voudrez en fonction des schémas
anciens que finalement vous évoquez et
dans lesquels les français ne se
reconnaissent plus cette politique est
en tout cas au service de la france et
de son redressement
et c'est bien cela et uniquement cela
qui compte sur un cap clair sur un
constat et des ambitions partagées entre
la majorité et le gouvernement sur un
contrat avec la nation et de ce point de
vue quand on regarde l'histoire
politique récente c'est une nouveauté
monsieur le premier ministre la tâche la
première tâche qui attend votre
gouvernement et qui annonce cette
nouvelle assemblée c'est celle de
retrouver la confiance de nos
concitoyens c'est lent tout premier et
cette confiance sera rétablie si nous
remplissons de deux conditions la
première c'est nous modifions nos
pratiques et notre rapport à la
démocratie
c'est tout le sens de l'engagement qui
est le nôtre pour soutenir le texte
pour la confiance dans notre vie
démocratique qui sera débattue
prochainement et auquel nous sommes très
attachés et cela va de pair avec la
réforme institutionnelle évoquée hier
par le président de la république et qui
sera une partie fondamentale de ce
nouveau lien meilleure représentativité
des grands courants de la vie politique
réduction du nombre de parlementaires et
en corollaire renforcement de leurs
moyens parce qu'il ne faudra pas céder à
la démagogie et à l'ambiance
inquisitoriale du moment amélioration de
nos procédures
tout cela va dans le bon sens le
deuxième c'est la méthode est l'état
d'esprit de notre action parlementaire
et celle de votre gouvernement
une nouvelle alliance de la loi et du
contrat du dialogue et du respect du
refus de l'anathème aussi et pour
résumer c'est une stratégie du
dépassement des antagonismes
nous connaissions mais rétablir la
confiance ne concerne pas le seul niveau
institutionnel et la méthode rétablir la
confiance et aussi krupa
en notre économie en aux entreprises et
à leurs facultés assurer la prospérité
de notre pays et des citoyens
c'est réconcilier la france avec ces
entrepreneurs s'est porté sur eux autre
chose qu'un regard convenu et disons le
tellement caricatural c'était conjuguer
compétitivité et justice sociale et marc
qui élit de l'indivisibilité des enjeux
économiques et sociaux il faut libérer
l'activité en permettant à ceux qui
peuvent et qui veulent entreprendre de
pouvoir le faire donner de l'autonomie
de la liberté et même la possibilité d'
échouer parce que c'est à ce prix que
l'on donne aussi la possibilité de
réussir et c'est pourquoi nous vous
soutiendrons lors de l'examen du projet
de loi sur le raf renforcement du
dialogue social et l'ensemble des
réformes qui viendront consolider ce
texte dans les mois qui viennent pour
lutter résolument contre le chômage
au delà des postures d'appareils
essayons de voir ce qui fonctionne ce
qui ne marche pas ou ce qui ne marche
plus sans dogmatisme et sans d'idéologie
rétablir la confiance c'est aussi
rétablir l'équilibré de nos comptes
publics
c'est une question vis-à-vis de nos
financeurs bien sûr de nos partenaires
européens évidemment mais c'est
peut-être en premier lieu et sur le fond
une question de confiance pour les
générations futures
comment voulez vous que nous trouvions
le moindre crédit politique auprès des
jeunes générations auxquelles on off
comme seule perspective le remboursement
de dettes dont ils ne sont pourtant pas
comptable cette dette là comme la dette
écologique
elle est à mon sens terrible parce
qu'elle mine si ce n'est si elle n'est
pas résolue toute capacité à agir pour
ceux qui nous succéderont est donc tout
simplement à espérer et pour la dette
écologique tout simplement la capacité à
vivre régler la question de la dette ce
n'est donc pas une question comptable
c'est d'abord et avant tout une question
morale vis-à-vis des français et en
particulier des plus jeunes d'entre nous
et nous sommes et nous soutiendrons dans
la droite ligne de nos engagements
anciens toutes les initiatives que vous
avez annoncé monsieur le premier
ministre pour remettre de l'ordre et de
la cohérence dans nos finances publiques
nous devrons le faire tout en gardant le
cap des engagements pris devant les
français par exemple sur la question du
pouvoir d'achat
ou dès que les investissements publics
et par exemple dans le domaine de la
transition énergétique mais monsieur le
premier ministre nous avait je vous
remercie d'avoir réaffirmer le cap et le
cap des réformes
en vous adressant à nous tout à l'heure
rétablir la confiance est aussi
s'adresser aux français de tous les
territoires
je suis l'élu d'un territoire urbain et
rural qu'on nombre d'entre nous j'assume
cette complémentarité et j'en suis fier
je ne les oppose pas je mets en garde
contre la tentation de le faire mais
nous devons veiller à ce que ne se
construisent pas de france qui
deviendrait irréconciliables dans leur
fonctionnement
celle pleinement partie prenante de la
mondialisation et celles rurales mais
également urbaines qui se verrait
cantonné dans le seul rôle de
spectatrice du monde pour ces
territoires la puissance publique des
formes qui nous faudra renouveler devra
s'exercer pleinement l'on imagine a
jamais assez le sentiment terrible de
déclassement d'un village ou d'un
quartier qui voit son dernier médecin
partir son école fermée où son dernier
commerce disparaître
et nous avons parallèlement besoin de
redonner à chaque territoire sa fierté
en lui donnant un rôle
j'allais dire une vocation dans la
production de richesse nationale
l'identité d'un territoire c'est aussi
son identité économique les savoir faire
de ses ouvriers et de tous ses salariés
et de tous ces entrepreneurs les
potentialités offertes par les
technologies du futur les défis
énergétiques et alimentaires l'émergence
d'une nouvelle économie sont autant de
potentiel que nous pourrions exploiter
pour peu que nous ayons une véritable
stratégie économique territoriale et une
politique d'aménagement du territoire
cohérente rétablir la confiance et enfin
retrouvé redonner du sens à notre destin
européen
comme vous l'avez rappelé monsieur le
premier ministre parler d'europe
c'est parler du destin de la france nous
ne sous-estimons pas les imperfections
du système européen en particulier la
question de sa légitimité démocratique
qui doit être renforcée si elle veut
retrouver son crédit auprès des peuples
l'europe doit se saisir principalement
des sujets qu'ils justifient d'une
stratégie et d'une politique européenne
grande politique industrielle sécurité
commune climat défense européenne
convergence économique et sociale tels
sont les enjeux à mettre d'urgence à
l'agenda européen
monsieur le premier ministre aurait
voulu vous parler d'éducation et de
culture parce que la société que nous
avons à construire procède finalement et
en premier lieu de cela de santé et de
solidarité aussi parce que c'est le défi
un devoir envers les plus fragiles
nous aurons l'occasion au cours des
travaux parlementaires de nous retrouver
sur ces sujets mais sachez que notre
groupe sera pleinement actif est investi
sur ces thématiques essentielles
monsieur le premier ministre la
confiance que le groupe mouvement
démocrate s'apprêtent à voter est forte
elle est loyal elle est exigeante pour
nous tant les défis sont nombreux
elle est porteuse de tous les espoirs
que portent les français pour que le
paint notre pays retrouve fierté et
optimise et s'est aussi d'une certaine
façon en leur nom que nous allons le
faire je vous remercie
merci
merci monsieur fesneau
[Applaudissements]